SIERRA: I’ll be the first to admit that I am
not a huge sports fan. I don’t follow the NBA,
and I tend to wander away from the TV during
football games. But I do love to watch the
Olympics. And that’s because it's actually
super cool to see whole nations rallying
behind one team. It becomes something more than
a game. It becomes this uniting cultural moment.
It’s like a global holiday. And so, with a
little bit of extra couch time on my hands,
I was very ready to tune into this summer’s
Tokyo Olympics. The perfect distraction.
But, the July 2020 Olympic Games aren't going
to be held this month. They’ve
been postponed. By a full year!
This decision wasn’t made lightly and in fact,
Japan is working around the clock to try to figure
out how to keep their games, despite a global
pandemic. It’s part of a long story. For decades,
just like their athletes, countries have
competed fiercely to host the games,
despite mounting evidence that they usually
represent a significant financial loss. And that
made us ask why? If not money, what do the games
offer that’s so special and worth so much effort?
I’m Gabrielle Sierra, and this is Why It
Matters. Today, the Olympics, Soft Power,
and the deep-running politics of the world games.
BOYKOFF:
For many sports, the Olympics is the apex of what
they can achieve as athletes. And it's a chance
for the world to see incredible, incredible
athletes out there on the world stage. My
name is Jules Boykoff and I teach political
science at Pacific University in Oregon.
SIERRA: Professor Boykoff has written four
books about the Olympics. And as it turns out,
he’s also a former member of the
U.S. Men’s Olympic Soccer Team.
BOYKOFF: And that is really why the Olympics
have stuck around and been so successful,
were it not for the athletes, we wouldn't
really have the Olympic games. Of course
the money shuffle has become a big part
of that, we can talk about that later. But
for athletes in lesser known sports say,
curling in the Winter Olympics, or maybe,
equestrian or something like that in the Summer
Olympics, this is their one chance to make it big.
MOON: You know, I think we have
to remember that the Olympics,
the Olympic games themselves are a value or
ideal-driven event. I'm Katherine Moon and I am
a professor of political science at Wellesley
College. I study issues related to East Asia,
particularly the Koreas and I love to talk about
culture, and values in international politics.
As much as we say it is about pure
athleticism and fair competition,
it really was and is about ideals as human
beings. The human spirit to strive for excellence,
and to do one's best, and to be proud to be
with others who are excellent in their fields.
And I think that's what drives people to go
to the Olympics and to watch the Olympics.
NBC: Get the gold medals ready!
Olympic:It’s changed my life completely.
NBC: Oh my gosh! Unbelievable!
Olympic: It’s all cultures and
all values coming together...
RT: Chanting.
NBC: This is huge. This is really big.
SIERRA: So it's July and you know, we
were supposed to start watching the
Summer Olympics in what, like about
a week. So what the heck happened?
BOYKOFF: Yeah, the Olympics got coronavirus
and they had to push it back for a year. When
you look back at that moment, there were calls to
cancel the Olympics. There were calls to postpone
the Olympics and the members of the International
Olympic Committee seemed determined to press ahead
with the games. This at a time when other sports
were shutting down, world soccer was shutting
down various sports leagues around the world. And
yet the International Olympic Committee felt like
they needed to press ahead. And the real reason
why the IOC, The International Olympic Committee,
finally acted was because Canada basically said
they were going to do a de facto boycott if the
games were held in 2020. They were soon followed
by the national Olympic committees from Australia,
Portugal and Germany. And when that all happened,
the International Olympic Committee had no choice,
but to postpone. And that's exactly what they
did. So now they're slated for July 2021.
ITV: The inevitable has finally been confirmed.
CNN: The signs are all over Tokyo, symbols of what
was supposed to be a Japanese revival.
A comeback crushed, at least for now.
ABC: We’re talking about an event
that’s been seven years in the making,
billions of dollars spent,
involving 200 countries and
11,000 athletes. You can’t just
pick another date on the calendar.
SIERRA: The Olympic games have only been cancelled
three times. The first time was in 1916 during
World War I. The second and third time were
in 1940 and 1944, due to World War II. It’s
still unclear whether the 2020 games will become
a fourth, historic cancellation. The current plan
is to begin them on July 24th, 2021. But many
experts are skeptical of this timeline, arguing
that there is no guarantee that the coronavirus
will be fully under control in a year. Still,
the struggle to preserve the 2020 Games shows just
how invested host countries become in success.
SIERRA: What's at stake for
Japan as the situation plays out?
BOYKOFF: Well, Japan has plunged a lot of money
and prestige and human capital into making the
games happen. If we think back to when they were
originally bidding on the Olympics, they said that
the entire escapade would cost $7.3 billion. But
by the time the summer rolled around, they had
spent some $28 billion, according to an audit by
the Japanese government. And so that's four times
what they had originally planned. Postponing means
adding anywhere from 2 to $6 billion, those are
the best guesses that we have now. So what's at
stake for Japan is they've already spent way more
money than they expected. And now they might
not even get the Olympics to actually happen.
MOON: Prime Minister Abe's government had hoped
to use tourism around the Olympics as a way to
bring in the capital and the entrepreneurial
energy that he's been seeking for his country.
The primary reason why Japan has wanted to
host the Olympics is to jump start or jump
start again it's downtrodden economy. And I think
this has obviously failed given the pandemic,
but also in some ways, my own belief is that it
was a misplaced hope. Japan's desire to get back
on its feet economically as a major productive
global power based specifically on high-tech,
AI, artificial intelligence, as well
as energy efficient vehicles. That
these are not things that can be
accomplished through the Olympics.
SIERRA: Do you think that Abe sees the
Olympics as important to his legacy?
MOON: I think every political leader would
regard the Olympics or in countries that
highly value international football, hosting a
FIFA World Cup, these are major events. And we
know that that's the case in more recent years
with Brazil trying to do the Olympics and FIFA
World Cup. It puts a country on the map or it
draws attention to that country that already
may have been on the map. So every leader is
interested, but whether or not every leader
gets the kind of positive effect and impact
that they would like is really questionable.
SIERRA: The stakes for this type of positive
branding are even higher right now. Some see
the next games as an opportunity to be the site
of the world’s comeback from the pandemic and
economic recession. It’s a symbol that Japan
would love to claim for itself - and that China,
the next host, would be happy to receive
if the summer games end up cancelled.
MOON: Whether or not a country gains economically,
I think they like the idea that they might be able
to gain. Especially through tourist dollars.
And more importantly through name recognition
and as a way to show off their country. It's
almost like you size each other up through the
athletics as well as through the economic and
political competition and power games. And so,
there's a certain kind of a surrogacy I
think that goes on, but for the most part,
they want money. They want tourists and the
tourists are important because of the ability
to spread the good news about the country. Back
in 2008, in preparation for the Beijing Olympics,
both the Chinese government and the Chinese
society were really mobilizing average citizens,
to learn how to smile. These people were trained
how to smile, especially for Western tourists
who would be coming for the Olympic games.
And the 100,000 or so volunteers for the
Olympics games, uh, themselves, they were
given formal smiling training sessions.
SIERRA: Oh my gosh!
MOON: Yeah, so you know, this was all
a matter of looking appealing as a host
society. Looking welcoming, because
then tourists would go back and say,
"Wow, those Chinese people. They were so friendly.
They were kind. They smile all the time." I mean,
it's a little ludicrous that one would spend
one's energy that way, but on the other hand,
that's how important this image-making enterprise
called the Olympics can be to certain societies.
SIERRA: The world loves the Olympics. And
the attention of billions of viewers seems
to promise an opportunity for host
countries to redefine themselves on
the world stage. And when you look at it that way,
those 100,000 professionally-trained
smiles start to seem a little less absurd.
But the Olympics weren’t always what they are
now. How did we get here? When did the world’s
cities start spending billions of dollars to host
ski jumpers and pole vaulters every few years?
HistoryPod: On the 6th of April, 1896, the
first modern Olympic Games opened in Athens.
British Movietone: Specially built Olympic
stadium in Berlin is filled to capacity,
as Hitler arrives to preside at the opening
ceremony of the 11th modern Olympiad.
Channel 4 News: The Mexico Games of ‘68
two African American athletes stood on
the winners podium, heads bowed, gloved
hands raised in a black power salute.
Mountain Lake PBS: The 1980 Winter Olympics
are remembered today for the Miracle on Ice;
one of the greatest moments
in American sports history.
NBC: Every Olympics provides a snapshot of
a city and of a country at a point in time.
This one was more compelling than most,
as China’s rise and transformation is the
global story, not only of the moment
but likely of the foreseeable future.
BOYKOFF: So the Modern Olympics were the
brainchild of a plucky Baron from France
named Baron Pierre de Coubertin. And he was an
aristocrat who was very much dismayed by the
fact that the French had just gotten drubbed in
a war. And he thought that he could use sports to
toughen up what he called at the time, a flabby
youth who just got too soft. It sounds a little
bit curmudgeonly, and kind of odd, but I say all
that to say that the Olympics were sort of built
on a bed of contradiction. On one hand, the Baron
Pierre de Coubertin, wanted to start the Olympics
to toughen up the youth, to get them ready for
war. Uh, but he also used the games as this big
mechanism for peace. He thought that the women of
the time should not participate in the Olympics.
In fact, if you look at his writings, he said,
things like women should only be involved in the
Olympics to place the victory laurels on the heads
of men who won the gold medals and silver medals.
SIERRA: Oh, thanks.
BOYKOFF: He also had a lot of the
uh, racist sentiments of his time.
So he was a man of great sexism and
racism. He was also a man of great
persuasion and he persuaded a
lot of people to come along.
SIERRA: Wow. So he's got a
great name, but you know,
mixed bag there on the goals and the
original intent of the Olympic games.
BOYKOFF: Well, it's interesting too Gabby
because when he started the Olympics,
he got together a bunch of other Dukes and Counts
and Barons to create the International Olympic
Committee. So there was a real aristocratic flavor
from the very beginning of the Olympic games.
SIERRA: The growth of the Olympic games
into the global extravaganza we now
know was slow and steady. Only 11 nations
officially participated in the 1896 games,
but by 1936, at the infamous Berlin
Olympics, that number had grown
to 49. These games were also the first
to be televised and watched by a global
audience. With this audience came advertisers,
a process that culminated in the 1984 games,
sponsored in part by McDonalds. These became the
most financially successful in modern history.
By the Atlanta games of 1996, nearly
every nation on Earth was represented,
but it wasn’t until the London games of
2012 that all participating nations sent
female athletes. Took more than a century,
but we got there eventually. Cheers baron!
SIERRA: What trends have you noticed
over the decades about what kind of
countries are bidding or hosting the Olympics?
BOYKOFF: Sure. Well, for starters, a lot of the
bidding was incredibly competitive, especially
in the 1990s say and moving forward. But in
recent years there's been the rise of a lot of
criticism from critical journalists, from academic
writing, from activists in different cities and
human rights workers that has put it in a lot of
people's heads to maybe have a little more caution
in how they approach the Olympics. In terms of the
wider trends of why we're not seeing more bids,
those trends have also become more clear through
time and those trends are overspending. So I call
it Etch A Sketch economics, where during the
bid phase of the Olympics, the bidders say
that the Olympics will only cost so much, but
by the time the Olympics are actually staged,
it's actually many times that, the Tokyo games
are a perfect example of that. A second trend
is white elephant stadiums because the Olympics
has a lot of specialty sports like canoeing in
these whitewater rapid type scenarios. You have
to build these special venues that really aren't
going to be used afterwards and they often sit in
disrepair. So there are many pictures from say,
Athens where like the softball field is just
a bunch of weeds, or you look at more recently
Rio de Janeiro, where in the Deodoro complex,
where they built this specialized canoe run,
that's all boarded up and nobody can really
use it anymore. A third trend is displacement
and gentrification, 1.5 million people were
displaced to make way for the Beijing 2008
Summer Olympics. I lived in Rio de Janeiro
in the lead up to the 2016 Olympics as a
Fulbright research fellow and I saw for my
own eyes displacement happening. There some
77,000 people were displaced to make way for the
Olympics. Another trend with the Olympics is the
militarization of the public sphere. You're
seeing more and more people around the world,
viewing the Olympics as a terrorist target. This
was directly stated by Chechen rebel, Doku Umarov,
in regards to the 2014 Sochi Olympics, he said,
‘that's a legitimate terrorist target.’ And of
course we know from the political history of the
Olympics, that there was a terrorist attack at
Munich in 1972 and another one in Atlanta
in 1996. And so cities essentially use the
Olympics like their own private ATM machine
when it comes to securitizing the games,
getting all the special weapons and laws that they
would never be able to get during normal political
times. And those special weapons and laws stick
around after the games. A fifth trend that we
see time and again, is what a lot of people are
calling ‘greenwashing,’ which is to say making big
environmental promises during the bid phase, and
then not following through when it actually comes
to the delivery of the Olympics. And so it's those
trends that more and more people are becoming
aware of when they think about the Olympics that
is kind of scaring off cities from wanting to bid,
'cause the word is out on the street that
while the Olympics are full of the world's most
wonderful and talented athletes, they come with a
whole lot of social and political baggage as well.
SIERRA: Rusting stadiums, unfulfilled
promises, terrorist threats,
and deep financial losses. The list of
reasons not to host the Olympics is a
long one. And yet we still see countries
like South Korea, Japan, China, France,
and the United States spending millions of
dollars to win bids to host the games. Why?
MOON: I think there is always the perennial
hope that, "This time it'll be different for
my country. That this time my country will be
able to launch itself into the global economy
in a stronger light or be recognized as a
global power." If we look at Brazil in 2016,
that was the expectation. But also the reality is
that even if you don't make a whole lot of money
or even break even in preparing for the Olympics,
it does put people in your country to work. To
build stadiums and to renovate facilities. It also
raises the innovation and the upgrading skills of
a people. Especially if you are a developing
or an emerging economy. I think that when you
add the easy access of different marketing tools,
advertising as well as numerous companies in the
sporting world who are there to participate and
to sell their products, many countries can easily
see these opportunities as potential paths toward
further global integration and possibly growth.
SIERRA: It seems like some of what we've
been talking about has to do with soft
power. So I was wondering if you can maybe
explain a bit. You know, what is soft power?
MOON: Soft power is in contrast to the notion of
hard power, which of course is military power as
well as economic power that can be clearly
measured. Trade volume, for example. And so
when we think about soft power, we tend to look at
different factors or different tools of power such
as cultural influence, ideology, and institutional
appeal. It all relies on the power to attract.
It's more than just influence. It's really a
way to have a nation, by exerting soft power,
help shape the rest of the world to its
advantage. When we talk about soft power,
we have to include the biggest example
of soft power being American soft power.
And by that I mean three aspects. Liberal
democratic politics, free market economy,
and fundamental values and rights, including human
rights, freedom of speech, et cetera. And many
societies around the world since the 1990s have
tried to adapt to these notions of soft power.
And the Chinese for sure, when they held their
2008 Beijing games, their slogan was harmony.
And it's an interesting, um, uh, slogan given
that the Olympics are really about competition.
SIERRA: Right.
MOON: But the emphasis on harmony was
intended to signal to the rest of the world,
to the outside world, that they need not fear
China's rise. That China's rise will be peaceful
and harmonious. Will bring people together
and that it doesn't have to be riddled with,
contestation and potential violence the
way that some in the National Security
Establishment in the United States have
feared or still fear China's rise to be.
SIERRA: So, in the context of the Olympics,
there also seems to be a crossover between soft
power and, you know, maybe what everyday
people would think of as just branding.
MOON: I think branding of course,
countries try to do all the time,
but um, soft power has to have some
greater purpose than just selling goods.
Let's use South Korea as an
example. The 2018 winter Olympics.
ABC: The South Korean Government
saying they see preparations for
another ballistic missile test from North Korea.
CBC: So why are the Olympics so important for a
potential diplomatic opening? If history is any
guide, when it comes to the Koreas, sport
is one of the few ways to break the ice.
MOON: President Moon Jae-In of South Korea
at the time really wanted to use the Olympics
for two purposes. One was to entice North Koreans,
the North Korean regime, to open up. To come and
witness the possibilities of a good life. A
good society. A life of plenty in South Korea.
And then a second related point or goal being a
message to North Korea that you too can have this.
This is not just ours. You can share. If you
transform your political/economic orientation.
And so the goal was not to sell a South Korean
product or promote a South Korean industry per se,
which would really be about branding. But really
to transform a reality of military tension and
mistrust into one of possible reconciliation,
cooperation, and hopefully peace in the longer
run. And I would say that's a grander scheme,
but the problem there is that North Korea doesn't
really have a weakness. At least not yet, for the
soft power appeal of other countries. They've been
able to withstand and basically say, "No, thank
you," to many of the enticing aspects of Chinese
economic boom and the land of plenty compared
to North Korea. They know what's going on in the
South and they say, "No, thank you." They know
what's going on in Japan in terms of wealth and
influence and they say, "No, thank you." So
I think the part of international relations
scholarship and policy making around soft power
misses this point. That in order for soft power to
be effective, you need to have willing followers.
You need to have willing - meaning not coerced,
you need to have a certain spirit of volunteerism
toward transformation and adaptation. North Korea
is not a good candidate for that. I think a lot of
people develop quite a bit of hope that something
positive, nothing specific, but something positive
could happen. But in retrospect it looks like
South Korea worked really hard without getting
that much in return. So president Moon Jae-In
is getting a lot of criticism in his own country
for looking like a fool. For having been allegedly
naïve. And I think that's a very harsh criticism
because his intentions were very good and actually
there were signs that the two Koreas might be
able to move toward some sort of cooperation or
at least reduced hostilities. In retrospect, um,
you know, we can just easily say it didn't matter,
but who knows? Perhaps in 5, 10 years time, we
may look at Pyeongchang Olympics as the-the seed
that was planted in the middle of winter
that grew into something more fruitful.
SIERRA: Interpretations of the soft
powers and branding potential of the
Olympics will vary. But one thing is beyond
doubt. Alongside symbols of unity and pure
athletic achievement, the Olympics are political.
SIERRA: So looking back through history,
what do you see as some of the most interesting
Olympic games from a geopolitical perspective?
BOYKOFF: Oh, wow. There's just so many, right
from the beginning uh, that had geopolitical
implications. I think the ones that are probably
most known to the general public would certainly
be the 1936 Olympics in Berlin. If we think
about those Olympics at the time, Hitler was
just marshaling power and he was no fan of the
Olympics it turned out, uh. But his propaganda
minister Goebbels put the pressure on him and
said, "Oh, you're you gotta listen to this Hitler,
this is an incredible opportunity to spread the
gospel of Nazi-ism to the entire world." Hitler
listened and decided, okay, we'll make this thing
happen. And those games were used as a way of
making it seem as if what was happening in Germany
was normal when it was anything. And in the end,
the United States went and in some ways it
turned out to be a positive thing for the
athletes like Jesse Owens, who showed that
Hitler's theory of white supremacy was just
Hocus Pocus as Hitler had to stand there
while athlete after athlete Black athlete,
after Black athlete from the United States
was successfully hauling in the metals. So
that one is certainly one of them, but I think
you could kinda go through time and look at
just about every Olympics and talk about their
geopolitical implications. Some of the ones more
recently that have generated a lot of discussion
would certainly be the 1976 Olympics in Montreal,
as well as the 1984 Olympics in Los Angeles and
you could argue 1980 in Moscow as well. This was
at the height of the cold war when the Olympics
were essentially being used as a proxy for a
battlefield where the athletes from the United
States and the Soviet Union were going head to
head in the Olympics. And of course there was a
lot more at stake than just medals. It was pride,
it was standing in the international world
system. And so you can look at pretty much
every Olympics through the history of the games
and think about them through a geopolitical lens.
SIERRA: One way to see just how geopolitically
charged the olympics have been is to take a
look at its long history of boycotts.
While the United States did participate
in Hitler’s games - many Jewish athletes from
around the world refused to. Later, in 1976,
a total of 28 nations, including most of the
sovereign countries in Africa, boycotted the
Montreal games to protest Apartheid in South
Africa. In 1980, at the height of the cold war,
the United States led 66 nations into a
boycott of the summer games in Moscow. The
Soviet Union did something similar with their
own allies four years later. The list goes on.
SIERRA: Well, I mean, going
off of all of this you know,
the IOC claims that the Olympics are
nonpolitical, but it seems like they've
always been at least partly political.
So how realistic is that stated goal?
BOYKOFF: The Olympics groan under the
weight of an unreckoned political history,
deep contradictions are nestled at the core of
the entire Olympic project. When anybody who
takes a second to look at the games knows that
they're eminently political from top to bottom.
I mean, when it comes to politics, the
International Olympic Committee is living
in the past. Whereas politically minded Olympic
athletes are rooted in the present and they're
thinking about the future. And so to deny their
ability to speak out on the most important issues
of our time is to squelch their individuality
and to squelch their political descent.
So to step back and we think at this iconic
moment of Olympic activism from the 1968 Olympics,
where John Carlos and Tommie Smith stood on
the medal stand in Mexico city and thrust
their black glove fists into the sky during the
national Anthem, while the Australian sprinter,
Peter Norman stood by a silver medalist with
an Olympic project for human rights button on
standing in solidarity with the athletes, that's
become an iconic moment of Olympic history. And
it's also even bigger than that. It's an iconic
moment of world history. And when that happened,
the International Olympic Committee realized
that they needed to fortify the rules within
their Olympic charter to quell that kind of
activity. After 1968 is when they really get
it down in clear writing and they create a
rule that's embedded in the Olympic charter
that prohibits political activism inside or
around Olympic venues. If you fast forward
to today you have numerous athletes that are
speaking out on issues. So you take Gwen Berry,
the U.S. hammer thrower who put a fist in the
air reminiscent of Smith and Carlos, when she
was on the medal stand at the 2019 Pan American
Games, same for Race Imboden, the U.S. fencer who
took a knee at those same 2019, Pan Am Games in
Chile. And after that happened, the International
Olympic Committee essentially doubled down. And
earlier this year in January issued special rules
that were meant to fortify and be more specific to
the rule that's in the Olympic charter forbidding
dissent. And the new guidelines that were
issued in January by the International Olympic
Committee made it clear that hand gestures
or kneeling on the podium was forbidden.
SIERRA: These new rules can seem a bit ironic,
especially considering the fact that in 2019,
the US Olympic Hall of Fame inducted Smith
and Carlos in recognition of their iconic
protest. The fact that the IOC is sticking
with its ban has prompted many critics to
say they are out of step with the
times, and particularly with other
large sporting organizations that have
changed their rules to allow for dissent.
MOON: There is always a political context
if not a political goal or reasoning around
participation or lack of participation in
the Olympics. And I think, uh, what's ironic
is that the 2018 Pyeongchang games was about
the most blatantly political, on a diplomatic
level at least, very blatantly political,
Olympic event because of the North/South
temporary rapprochement at the games. So, you
know, it's not really fair to say that you can't
have protests, but you can have diplomacy
or diplomatic effort. As far as people's,
uh, desire to protest at Olympic venues,
I think that right now we are in a world
where protest has become almost a norm in
societies that are still allowed to protest.
You know, I think we have to remember that
the Olympics, the Olympic games themselves
are a value or ideal-driven event. And I look at
the Olympics a bit like the recent U.S. SpaceX
launch. I was really surprised to see so many
people on the NASA website from around the world
congratulating the astronauts, congratulating the
space program, and saying that we are with you at
a time when the United States is so unpopular
and is really in an embarrassing situation on
the global stage. So, the Olympics is a bit like
that. That it says something to people that,
"Oh my goodness. We can do this!" "Wow. I would
like to do this." And I think it's a wonderful
thing to see human excellence and for the athletes
of course, that is what they are striving for.
SIERRA:
So when Professor Moon mentioned SpaceX, this
memory jumped into my head. It happened more
than a year ago, on this podcast, when we
spoke with NASA administrator Charles Bolden,
and he said something I’ll never
forget. He told me about the awe
he experienced the first time he saw the
earth from space, a world without borders,
a world, in his words, “as it should
be, rather than the way it is.”
The Olympics, for all their problems, give us
perspective. Every two years we get to see the
nations of the world in competition without
violence. Like the view from the international
space station, this insight doesn’t fix any
particular global problem. Still, it’s hard
to measure the importance of the view itself,
and what the world might look like without it.
Want to dive deeper with three and a half
somersaults into the Olympics? Think of CFR.org
as your starting line to run the extra mile
with more content to read and watch. Interested
in saying hi to the Why It Matters team? You can
always reach out on email at whyitmatters@cfr.org.
If you are a fan, subscribe to the show
on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, Stitcher,
or wherever you get your audio. And if you
think we are a winning team, leave us a review!
Why It Matters is a production of the Council
on Foreign Relations. The show is created and
produced by Jeremy Sherlick, Asher Ross, and
me, Gabrielle Sierra. Our sound designer is
Markus Zakaria and our summer intern is Wynne
Dieffenbach. Robert McMahon is our Managing
Editor, and Doug Halsey is our Chief Digital
Officer. Teagan Judd and Rafaela Siewert provided
research and extra help on this episode so
in our books, they both scored the gold.
Original music is composed
by Ceiri Torjussen. Special
thanks go to Richard Haass and Jeff Reinke.
For Why It Matters this is Gabrielle Sierra,
signing off see you at the finish
line! Ok im done, promise (Laughs).